So much of mapping is focused
on lat long coordinates, but
who ever knows those?
A really important feature in the Google
Maps APIs is the ability to go back and
forth between lat longs and places,
like the happiest place on earth.
This is called geo coding, taking
an address and getting the lat wrong.
And reverse geocoding, getting
the address or place from a lat long.
We'll test out using the geocoding API,
VN HTTP request,
to get a lat long back from an address.
I copied this request right
from our developer sites.
All of the requests start out
in the same name space, and
then specify the service, and the output
format, in either JSON or XML.
We then specify the input parameters.
The required parameters here are only
the address and your API key.
We can also optionally include things
such as the component restriction,
to limit the results to a city or
a country.
Or a region bias to tell the geocoder
that certain regions are better than
others for the results that you expect.
Let's execute this and
see what we get back.
Okay, at the highest level we
get back a few things here.
The first thing that we'll
look at its the status.
This tells us whether our
request was successful, and
is also largely shared between
the various web services.
There are several
possibilities that we can see.
OK, means it found one or more results,
so that is the one we want.
Invalid request, means something
wasn't right in our request.
Unknown error, usually means there's
some kind of error on the server, and
the request can be repeated
until it's successful.
We'll talk later about over
query limit errors and
also request denied errors, so
don't worry about those yet.
The address component section has
information broken down into things such
as street, town, neighborhood,
country, state, etc.
We also get a formatted address
that we can use on its own.
The geometry contains the lat
long of the actual location and
other important info.
And finally we get a place ID which
is another unique identifier for any
place ranging from a whole country down
to the granularity of a single address.
We'll use that in conjunction with
the places API later in the course.
Right now we're interested in
the geometry, so let's focus on that.
This location is the lat
long that we're looking for.
The location type is
also very important.
This tells us more about
the point that we got back.
Since this is a rooftop, it means we
got an exact match for our location.
Other values could be range interpolated
which means that the geocoder
approximated a point based
on surrounding points.
Or geometric center, which means
that we got the center of a line.
For example, if we had searched only for
a road without an address,
we would get the center of that road.
Let's take another look at
the address components.
If we had done reverse geocoding,
for example, and specified
a lat long in our request instead of an
address, we'd be looking for this data.
We can get the exact street address, or
we can pull out other useful things.
For example, the county, or
that this address is on
the Upper East Side of Manhattan.
Typically, the components contain more
information than the formatted address.
So if you needed
the detailed information,
you'd need to parse through them.
The link in the instructor
notes has some detailed info on
all the address components.
>> Before we go back and
improve our listings app
let's review some stuff about
the HTTP requests and responses.